i like how you said um around 2008
so you're not uh
you know some people suggested you might
be satoshi nakamoto you previously said
you're not i'm not
you're not for sure
would you tell us if you were yes okay
uh do you think it's a feature of bug
that he's anonymous or she or they
it's an interesting kind of quirk of
human history that there is a particular
technology that is a completely
anonymous inventor
or creator
well i mean you can you can look at the
evolution of ideas
before the launch of bitcoin
and
see who wrote
you know about those ideas
um and then
i like i don't know exactly obviously i
don't know who created bitcoin for
practical purposes but
the evolution of ideas is is pretty
clear for that and like it seems as
though like nick sabo uh is probably
more than anyone else uh responsible for
the evolution of those ideas
so
he claims not to be
nakamoto but
i'm not sure that's that's neither here
nor there uh but he he seems to be the
one more responsible for the ideas
behind bitcoin than anyone else
so it's not perhaps like singular
figures aren't even as important as the
the figures involved in the evolution of
ideas that led to a thing so yeah yeah
it's you know
most perhaps it's sad to think about
history but maybe most names will be
forgotten anyway what is the name anyway
it's a name a name attached to an idea
what does it even mean really
you